it feels like you've conquered you know
the music world you're in the smash hit
movies but you've also it seems like
you've solved the restaurant every so
many people so many celebrities start a
restaurant doesn't work out right you
started a restaurant and it sounds like
a great idea and I understand it's doing
very well and it's called it is called
chicken and beer chicken and beer keep
things simple that's genius yeah man
sometimes it just takes to be very
simple with things but I it was the name
of my third album cuz I have like nine
albums right so third album this was
around the time where I was doing a lot
of drinking and a lot of smoking at the
same time and don't you know people were
like what are you gonna name this next
album and I was like well I mean what is
Ludacris all about what am i doing and
drinking a lot of damn beer and eating a
lot of damn chicken right from there he
came up with chicken a beer who who
would have thought in a million years
that years later down the line we'd make
a very successful restaurant because of
that out and this restaurant is it's in
Atlanta concourse D the busiest airport
in the world Atlanta hartsfield-jackson
airport man it's a beautiful thing yeah
and I hear people are going from gates
that are far away like I always when I'm
in an airport I eat at whatever's
closest to me even if it's food I
despise if it's near my gate I'll eat
there you know but people are walking
like miles to go to your restaurant yeah
man it's a destination restaurant so you
know everybody's hearing about it and
they're making it a point to go eat
there so I greatly appreciate all of
that and like I said I just love the
journey man Aloha
you